hi I'm Matt Welch for reason TV here in
Las Vegas at freedom fest and I'm joined
today by David Kirby vice president at
Freedom Works he's also policy and his
analyst at the Cato Institute and for
the purposes of this conversation has
also been doing very interesting work
over the years with des Vosges over
quedo looking at the libertarian vote in
America now you were just telling me
off-camera that you're doing some
interesting research about the word
libertarian it's right Elspeth well the
research that David bows and I have been
doing for the last 10 years is looking
at libertarian voters the people who
broadly construed or fiscally
conservative but socially liberal
they're the independent minded voters
the moderates that you talk about in
your book Declaration of Independence
the word libertarian though you know
we've always had as this operating
assumption is this clunky word that
nobody knows they're confused about it
or not you're not choosing to identify
them cells as libertarian even if they
have those background beliefs but we've
noticed in the last 15 months an uptick
and the number of people who are
actually self-identifying as libertarian
so basically freedomworks conducts polls
of its own members and right now we have
a big community it's about 4 million
people on facebook and 2 million people
on our email list and we asked them are
you libertarian and in December 2011 at
the beginning of the Republican
presidential primary season thirty
percent said yes I'm libertarian which
is still a big number but fifteen months
later we just finished a poll where we
found that thirty-eight percent of this
very same group are now calling
themselves libertarian now that's an
eight percentage point increase over a
period of 18 months now that may not
sound like a lot but in political
science terms this is actually a really
radical shift it's almost like we've
heard about polling on gay marriage
where suddenly like the public's views
on gay marriage shifted radically over a
period of two or four years and early
indicators were about an eight
percentage point increase and then it
flips over to a 20-percent a percentage
point increase sort of this it's kind of
wave that comes and maybe this is an
early indicator that this word
libertarian has started
kijan it's an interesting we first
interviewed Rand Paul back and I think
in two thousand and ten or so or he was
talking about how he didn't like to use
the word libertarian fact he wrote a
piece for the USA Today when he was
first running for Senate saying
libertarian not so fast and he preferred
to call himself a constitutional
conservative um now he goes around
saying the GOP is going to exist it
needs to become more libertarian yes he
calls himself a libertarian conservative
so you see even and he explained to us
he thought that libertarian was a scary
word yes two people in Kentucky didn't
wanna freak him out yeah now he's lost
that fear yeah I mean Rand Paul Ron Paul
they've certainly popularized the word
but another interesting thing is going
back the conservative media icon
recently on his television shows that
have no longer conservative i consider
myself libertarian now a lot of
libertarians are like i'm back as a
libertarian but what he's signaling to
his audience is that this word no longer
has a negative connotation it's
something that's positive especially
with NSA with IRS snooping all these
sort of civil liberties kind of issues
that kind of are exercising or kind of
liberal libertarian outraged citizens
are beginning to kind of see this as a
kind of place that's a comfortable way
to say yeah i'm i'm part of that
interestingly among this like eight
percentage point increase who's changing
they're actually more socially
conservative people so so it's actually
kind of a glenn beck audience type who
who are beginning to self-identify as
libertarian when previously they might
have called themselves conservative or
socially conservative um how much do you
think that's just a case of that the
people in charge of democrats and
whenever there's democrats running
things then republicans discover
conservatives discover their inner
libertarian i'm sure that's a factor but
these people have no love for the
republican party so we tacked on another
question on her poll that said okay only
thirty-eight percent think they're
libertarian but which best describes you
libertarian or republican and
eighty-eight percent said libertarian
which is actually astonishing I mean how
low the Republican Party has gone
and it's and it's kind of distrust among
its own voters I mean these are tea
party people who probably vote
Republican a very high rate but why is
that it's because the Republican
establishment is like going after
libertarian and libertarian leaning
Republicans like in the media you saw
Karl Rove recently called Justin Amash
the most liberal Republican in Congress
which is just outrageous is a
libertarian republican he scored a
hundred percent on freedomworks
scorecard one hundred percent on Cato
scorecard a hundred percent of Club for
Growth scorecard but Karl Rove is
threatened by a Justin Amash who might
run in in Michigan as a Senate candidate
because he's got his establishment pic
no doubt that he wants to moat of course
you know Bill Kristol and the neo-cons
are already trying to take down Rand
Paul you know going after one of his
staffers because his views on foreign
policy so it seems like the
establishment Republicans are probably
more scared of this kind of libertarian
energy that's sort of bubbling up from
the bottom up and that's a good time
what's the upshot of an eight percentage
point increase like why should people
who are not named David Kirby or Matt
Welch care that there are more
self-identified libertarians out there I
think it goes down to like how people
see themselves in this political
marketplace like that brands are so
tired the Republican brand the Democrat
brand especially among young people like
nobody wants to play this game we've got
all these choices that we have in our
private life between iphones and android
or all the things that you can you can
choose and now we're having more options
so what i think is happening is you're
having the reality of political identity
kind of finally catch up to the reality
of like the for-profit marketplace of
the explosion of choices and now if this
sort of identity emerges you have
another option where citizens like you
who who believe these same things can
talk about it in a way with a shorthand
word even if it's a clunky word like
libertarian and understand whether you
check whether each other are coming from
awesome libertarian vote in America
David Kirby thanks so much for joining
us for recent TV I'm Matt well